c'est évidemment l'information du jour
l'ouverture du procès des époux munch
macé il comparaissait cet après-midi
devant le tribunal correctionnel de
tours accusé d'avoir détourné 350 mille
euros au préjudice de la page 37
l'association pour adultes et jeunes
handicapés lui est accusé de faux usage
de faux et d'abus de confiance
elle de recel d'abus de confiance sur
place on retrouve romain delville
bonsoir aux mains alors la question
centrale du jour c est ce que l'ancienne
première adjointe de la ville de tours
pouvait ignorer que son mari puisé dans
les comptes de la page pour combler leur
propre dette
tout d'abord ils sont entrés séparément
dans la salle du tribunal cathy munch
masse et prend place sur le banc des
prévenus tandis que guillaume masse et
s'installe dans la salle du public ils
se retrouvent ensuite côte-à-côte
séparer on va dire d'un mètre pour
s'expliquer à la barre durant tout
l'après-midi le fond de la sphère est
assez simple guillaume masse et l'ancien
directeur de la page 37 à trafiquer des
factures par des collages découpages
assez grossier d'ailleurs selon la
présidente du tribunal et a fait des
chèques à son nom pour éponger des
dettes personnelles l' enquête révèle 24
chèque et plus de 350000 euros détournés
à l'audience lui même dit ne pas
comprendre comment ces barrières morales
son éducation ne l'ont pas empêché n'ont
pas empêché ses agissements de son côté
cathy munch masse et dit avoir découvert
l'ampleur du péril financier selon ses
termes lors de sa garde à vue en
novembre dernier sur les crédits
contractés par son mari l'ancien élu de
tour assure qu'elle ne savait rien qu
elles ne contrôlaient jamais ses comptes
une confiance en son mari lui l'ancien
fonctionnaire des finances publiques une
confiance qu'elle estime trahi malgré
les questions répétées de la présidente
du tribunal cathy munch masse et
maintient sa version celle d'une épouse
qui ignore les mouvements bancaires au
sein du couple au delà des dettes de
près de crédit à la consommation en fait
c'est la vie d'un couple de ces non-dits
l'illusion ses aveuglements ces
tromperies aussi et ses négligences qui
mise à nu devant le tribunal pour
remettre les comptes du couple à 0 diom
masse et reconnaît avoir triché pour
préserver sa famille oui mais au
détriment d'une association humanitaire
à la barre guillaume masse et des
douanes son épouse en tous points et
assume ses détournements d'une voix
calme et posée alors quelles
conséquences judiciaires pour les deux
prévenus le concernant ils encourent
jusqu'à sept ans d'emprisonnement et 750
mille euros d'amande pour elle la peine
maximale est fixée à 5 ans au moment où
je vous parle le procès continue merci
romain et merci à audrey champigny qui
vous accompagnent